Laetitia Hallyday porte plainte pour
injures publiques suite à des propos
tenus contre sa fille de 14 ans Joy dans
l'émission Touche pas à mon poste le 30
janvier 2023 la chroniqueuse Kelly
Vedovelli commentait des vidéos Tik Tok
de Joy Hallyday en employant les termes
suivants pour moi c'est le summum de la
vulgarité pour moi c'est hyper vulgaire
avec sa langue ça bouge c'est nichon que
ce soit elle ou une autre adolescente tu
peux pas faire ça parce que c'est la
nouvelle génération on a le droit d'être
des tenues selon l'avocat des Hallyday
interrogé par l'AFP ses propos
outrepassent les limites admissibles de
la liberté d'expression dès lors que
leur victime est une adolescente âgée de
14 ans pour rappel selon l'article 33 de
la loi de 1881 sur la liberté de la
presse l'injure peut être puni d'une
amende allant jusqu'à 12000 euros la
sanction peut même être plus lourde
jusqu'à un an d'emprisonnement et 45000
euros d'amende si l'injure est commise à
raison du sexe de la personne injuriée
un signalement pour violation de
l'obligation de respect des droits de la
personne et violation de l'obligation de
maîtrise de l'antenne a également été
lancée auprès de l'Autorité de
régulation des médias lard com